all right coming up any second now 5s 5
standard let's do it
here we go though all right got the
white side again let's try e 4 again
another Carroll no French defense ok a
widow are let's try the winnow are
paulsen variation and SCOE 5 as you get
very wacky very strategical now what do
I want run in grab a pond here I'm not
really a big fan of that so let's try
something else
what could that something else be just
Knight f3 hmm I like my enough 3
and now what I think eventually okay no
now probably that right away because
there is a variation where this Bishop
just plants itself on a for provides a
complete lockdown on the Queen side and
then this King is allowed to safely go
to that Queen side and I do not have a
successful pawn break you catch all that
I know I was rattling that off pretty
quickly I have to go back to that the
very important detail you can find
yourself strategically crushed and then
you'd kind of be scratching your head
like where did I go wrong
what could I do why would why am I not
able to develop a cool plan well it
might be because this bishop is allowed
to get to a four maybe anyhow what
should I be doing in the meantime Bishop
d3 Bishop e2 this guy probably here but
not just yet that would obstruct the
rooks view of a four is there gonna be a
better spot than d3 for my light square
bishop probably not okay I'm coming here
and it it may be very tempting to as
black to play seafloor because you're
like hey I'm you know I'm throwing a one
move threaded my opponent but that again
will resolve the tension in the center
and I will have to worry that much less
about my d4 pawn its castle
I think rook to e1 is a purposeful move
to run with I do want to be in a
position I want to be prepared to me
takes with pawn recapture and we might
be having like knight c6 some take
stakes in the knight to be four in some
variations I might want to be taking
that into accounts on knight c6 maybe
Bishop to d2 also rook to e1 to meet c4
with maybe the bishop coming all the way
back I'm not quite sure or what about
now Bishop to a3 I think [ __ ] of a
three-night a5 and then I have to do
something about this guy I don't know
how great that's gonna be so maybe I
just allow
yeah I do have a plan my plan is if they
go with this capture in the play night
to be four I'm gonna let my bishop just
sit there and I'll allow the knight to
capture it and I'm prepared to capture
with my pawn and again the pawn
structure will have changed my bishop on
d2 I think will still be very well
placed maybe facilitating a5 maybe
looking to pivot on b4 and then get on
this diagonal and now hmm
Bishop takes and then pawn push pressure
on this guy I could do g4 but that's an
extremely committal move extremely
committed I think g4 eventually h4
becoming black Oh Black has not yet
committed their King the rook is still
on that H file so I don't know if I want
to do that right away again Bishop 8 395
g4 now I don't really want to do that
how about man
Bishop back no g4 I'm stuck stuck I'm
stuck I'm stuck my pawn is looking for
weaknesses right here they're trying to
get me to do this move I don't know if I
wanna do that move let's take that night
it's too much of a pain
oh I'm winning this pond what am i doing
oh that's convincing enough oh let's
just open the position up why didn't I
see that these are all like pretty
forcing moves these capturing moves are
they can allow me to grab this pun they
probably should hang on to it Bishop e6
and if I'm gonna take again then this
rook comes to life but I'm not gonna
take I think that this move is better
I don't want again I'm not taking here
cuz that rook is gonna spring to life so
now big trouble where is this King go
queenside castle that's pretty crazy if
I get my Bishop to d6 and it looks like
I will be able to iPhone has a difficult
road ahead these pawns are ridiculous
looking maybe triple pawns but again one
of them is just an extra so less than
two my opponent three I think I just
gobbled this guy up let's do that right
away I'm okay with giving that guy up
maybe Bishop to b4 Bishop d6 Bishop d6
well like I like Bishop b4 this is
stringing everything together Knight d4
is a nice home for my knight where does
this King go I think there's problems
for the king Knight d4 there is Knight
to be too maybe this is gonna be a
problem but I'm just saying bad things
happening like Queen h5 and I'm
threatening Knight takes Bishop here if
this pawn has to move that's an
additional dark square that my opponents
can have to worry about namely f6 my
queen could also then be slipping into
h6 so I have good posts for my minor
pieces this Bishop is much more valuable
well it's worth more than three points
say that much so now let's get my Queen
out and about again Knight takes bishop
is on the cards
if King site if excuse me queenside
castle a5 could come very quickly and
yeah hmm now what what is my opponent to
g6 again Queen h6 you're not getting rid
of the Queen so easily she's there's
only one minor piece and a bunch of
pawns that can maybe chase her away but
that's okay now now looking for g6 next
hmm okay I like that move okay well how
about I am play f4 no no no no let's not
do that
oh wait might be 5/2 Knight decent might
be five 2d six oh man this could be a
really um effective plan right very very
effective plan not only is a bishop may
be strongly placed earlier I was
referencing a bishop there but now a
knight there the knight is also two
different squares available to it
um okay so I'm gaining back sometime I
think Queen back here or just all the
way back I'm gonna come all the way back
I think g5 was just gonna be played so
I'm content with this and if the Knights
are off the board it's gonna come down
to an opposite color Bishop ending and
as we all know opposite color Bishop
endings are drawn right not really not
really not in this situation there's too
much firepower that's a past pun and I
did that to open up this efile not only
for my rook but I want my Queen to be
able to pivot on these dark squares so
now this is a big issue a very very big
issue right here I'm looking for Queen
f6 and then Queen takes rook sneaking in
sneaking in right here
I think Queen here is necessary rook
takes Bishop coming up also just see for
Bishop to that Bishop to c3 is on the
cards like the Queen has to go I'm okay
with giving up some pawns just to get my
Bishop on a better diagonal let's do
this and let's guard this past pawn my
bishop was no longer there to watch over
at 31 seconds if this bishop moves rook
to e7 is brutal okay let's let's do what
let's move fast let's go here I'm
looking for me to Bishop d2 queen g4
stuff let's hang on to that pond still
dark square weaknesses it's back up now
my bishop is extremely versatile and now
there's big problems making too dark
square issues okay
this if you take a good game this is if
you just take a quick snapshot this is
not like it's not just by chance like
when you when there is those opposite
colored bishops you know sometimes like
when you have those heavy pieces you're
gonna want to be moving them about on
light squares and sure enough in that
triangle position there's like you know
you got all the major pieces the Queens
and the rooks find themselves on light
squares because otherwise this Bishop
could just be harassing them
so okay let me back up this again winnow
are French could turn out to be very
very strategic game this right here was
one that I was speaking quite a bit
about well isn't as much as I could
during the game but this Bishop d7 move
comes with the thought of just cementing
the bishop on a four you know I wish I
could go into analysis mode right now
but I can't so I could actually um
instead of just rattling off the moves
with naming coordinates etc I could
actually move the pieces but if I don't
play a four I think Bishop to a four it
turns out to be very strong
maybe there's thoughts of like taking
here and trying to hang on to it but
assuming like I can't like win materials
in a successful way again just this idea
Bishop a4 is Bishop a4 and then
something like c4 and then b5 how do I
break that structure down how do I break
down a structure if you can envision
this pawn excuse me this Bishop on a4
I've let this black pawn just clamping
down just playing c4 and then has a
follow-up be 5 so Bishop on a4 pawn on
d5 pawn on c4 how do I break that down
and what does this guy do if these two
pawns right here I can't move then this
Bishop is shut down on the Queen side
and if h6 is played what can this Bishop
do that's even constructive so you know
if you happen to be playing the white
side of this be very cautious of that
idea there is a difference you know
black I think does well to maybe do this
move prior to 96 if you do Knight c6
Bishop d7 would not be threatening to
come there so just switching the move
order is making me do that a4 move right
away and that actually turns out to not
be a good choice and it took me a while
to even see the variation where I could
be netting upon but um
yeah we'll be something better probably
castle or just maybe Knight to a5 again
I was I was prepared to me let's say CD
CD night before with just Bishop to d2
giving up my light square Bishop Knight
takes bishop on takes and then with
still opposite color bishops I think I'm
in a pretty decent spot I have a lot of
control over the entry points on the c5
I think things would be all right there
but again probably a 95 or yeah 95 I
think is a pretty good I don't know
decision time where maybe h6 just kind
of waiting a bit not allowing me to
pivot on g5 with my bishop or Knight
maybe preparing like a queenside castle
somehow c4 time lessee for shutting down
the Queen side and then playing on the
Kings side is available again there's
there's so many I think there's a
handful of plans that black could be
running with here it's okay it's a
battle of plans at this point a
strategical battle but um I think after
I net upon him [ __ ] and definitely
better here it's not really gonna be
anything good as far as I could tie
don't know if I gave my opponent a
window of opportunity anywhere yeah it
gets to be pretty rough here dark square
weaknesses in the past pawn this Bishop
is obstructed by their pawns so alright
let's close out